i'm barbara mead I'm one of the owners
here at politics and prose bookstore and
it is my pleasure tonight to welcome
Moises Naeem to politics and prose to
talk about his new book illicit I
actually read this whole book in galle
about a month ago and I was so impressed
by it that I put it in our holiday
newsletter I thought it was really an
important book our author comes with a
very distinguished resume he's been
editor of foreign policy for more than a
decade and before that he was an
executive director of the World Bank I
found that it was very interesting of
how that he got in started into this
book I don't know whether that he would
call himself naive I may be
overestimating that but he started out
many years ago while doing his
editorship to that he wanted to
investigate globalization further and he
said he started out being interested in
the subject and it wasn't very long
before he was personally fascinated with
the subject he just couldn't get away
from it because that when he started to
think about globalization the more he
read he couldn't write something that
was to say that globalization was good
he couldn't write something to say the
globalization was bad but he could write
something to let us although what we
haven't known before and that is
globalization is very different than
what we think of it so far it's
different in that it has a huge
underbelly we can't count it because
it's all below the radar of a huge
underbelly of Commerce which relies upon
networks words are not different from al
Qaeda networks their sophisticated
networks I have a lot of good technology
they're stateless and they can operate
with extreme efficiency in moving arms
drugs human beings money
to a property all those things across
borders in an extent that we just are
very very ignorant of and so that's
exactly of why that he wrote the book
illicit it's a for all of us who have
been naive before it's a tremendous
education of what is going on out there
in our global economy which we have just
not known anything about before so I
welcome boys this name to politics and
prose thank you for the kind
introduction and the opportunity to
thank you all for making the time to
being here tonight and let me start by
telling you more about how I got
involved in the in the book as Barbara
said I am NOT a lawyer I don't come from
a background of law enforcement I'm not
a criminologist I I am the editor of
foreign policy magazine and that puts me
often in touch with people that are
thinking about how the world is changing
and so we track what we call the
surprises of the new interconnections
the new strains very often surprising
ways in which the world now is connected
and why how what happens there matters
here and vice versa and that was my
frame of mind and in the mid 90s I was
walking the streets of Milan and I ran
into a street vendor that was selling
very very expensive bags for a fraction
a tiny fraction of the price that the
original store just a few blocks away
was selling them from I engaged in a
conversation with this person and very
quickly I discovered that he was as he
listed as the back he was selling he had
been trafficked from West Africa here he
was he had to pay the traffickers to
bring him to Italy and he wasn't now
indebted to them and he was working very
long hours horrible working conditions
in order to try to repay what was
obviously an unpayable debt and after
that I
on my way back to the states I stopped
in in New York and I was walking the
streets of Manhattan and lo and behold
what did I find another street vendor
that was selling exactly the same bag I
also started talking to to this person
and quickly discovered that he was as he
listed as his back as he listed as his
counterpart in Europe except that they
didn't know each other they were from
different countries but the stories were
identical and so I that got and then I
started asking more and then just think
about the complexity of this operation
just think about first you have to steal
the design from some company that or is
already aware that people are trying to
steal the resins and therefore is very
careful to protect it and very often
these counterfeits are marketed before
you can find the counterfeits before the
original products are marked merchandise
in many instances so first you have to
steal the design then you have to take
it to some place in the world typically
very often it's China in China you have
to get all the raw materials the buckles
and the ladder the belts and everything
that goes in this back assuming is the
back it could be a watch it could be a
garment so you have to procure exactly
the same materials put it together
assemble it and prop manufacture it in
the thousands then put it in containers
and ship it to all the capitals of the
world more or less at the same time and
then use as your merchandising as your
retail operations all sorts of traffic
people from different parts of the world
if you ask any top manager from a
multinational corporations to do this
they will tell you that this is a very
very difficult managerial challenge is
not easy to do this well add to the fact
that each one of these transactions that
I just described is illicit is a crime
and so just imagine the amount of money
the amount of complicity the amount of
government involvement that has to go
into these trades and then of course the
profits are huge then
numbers are staggering and that is what
led me to look at all the trades and I
looked at the trade in narcotics the
drugs they trade in weapons from small
arms to weapons of mass destruction
nuclear bomb making technology to
endanger species all kinds of logging
goes on that is illegal and illicit and
traded and billions industrial waste the
more countries become aware of
environmental pollution and the more
they pass laws the more there is an
incentive for people to outsource the
disposal or the garbage so they are
willing to pay others to take it and
dispose it and there are others willing
to do that for a price and very often
they dispose it in somewhere else
somewhere else is typically a place
where again governments are willing for
a bride to allow to the dumping of the
industrial waste this is a huge industry
worldwide and I started looking at all
of these things all of these trades and
discovered that they are changing the
world that's the main point of the book
is that these markets this illicit
market is black markets are changing the
world this is a very bold assertion to
make because alyssa trade black markets
smuggling has been with us since time
immemorial the first time a government
or an authority attempted to stop human
beings from moving goods or people from
one place to another through a border
that's the moment we're smuggling we
give existence started to appear in the
history of humankind so smuggling black
markets illicit trades and very old so
why is it that I can argue or that I'm
willing to argue that illicit rates
today are even more important and are
transformational and that's the point
that's what I try to do in the book and
in a nutshell the argument is that it's
no longer that they have grown in size
and they are now global and I will talk
a little bit about that but very
importantly the is that they have
come far more political they have now
intertwined with governments government
officials in very complex ways and they
are transforming the way politics is
conducted both in some specific
countries at regional levels and there
are even more global international
political consequences let me first talk
a little bit about the numbers and again
the the very valid question is where are
these numbers coming from because all of
these are secrets illicit activities how
do you measure well there are ways of
measuring directly there are estimates
you there are these arguments about the
estimates and you know are we talking
about the human trait the trading human
beings is it seven billion dollars or is
it 12 billion dollars well you could
argue about that what no one no one
argues is that they are shrinking there
is not one single expert that has
seriously looked at this market that
will tell you that today these markets
are smaller in volume and scope that
they were ten years ago no one and there
are indirect indicators in drugs the
number of drug busts is always
interpreted to be a fraction of what
really goes on money laundering is a
very interesting proxy because at the
end of the day all of these trades
generate profits and revenues that have
to enter into the arteries of the
international financial system so you
saw how measure money laundering you
have a guess of these things the money
laundering has grown ten times to what
it was in 1990 these two day ten times
larger and it's over a 1 trillion more
than one trillion dollar in today and
it's ten percent of all legitimate trade
this is one estimate that is considered
by some to be conservative they're all
their larger estimates but if you take
the most conservative one it is huge
drugs some of you may remember a movie
called the French Connection about the
heroin trade in Marseilles remember the
numbers there were tiny tiny compared to
what they are two
a in 1991 for example even a few decades
after that the French Connection the
illegal trading drugs was reckoned to be
at about 61 billion dollars today is it
estimated at nine hundred billion
dollars counterfeits counterfeits used
to be shoddy and remember made in Hong
Kong and made in Taiwan it was it always
existed but it was not a very huge trade
now it is very sophisticated almost
identical and it's 630 billion dollars
per year is it weapons is about the
trade day Lisa trading weapons small
arms we're not talking aircraft carriers
and tanks we're talking small arms small
arms that accounts for thousands of
deaths each day in the world it is
estimated that only three percent of the
small weapons now in circulation in the
world are in the hands of law
enforcement and governments ninety-seven
percent of the small weapons are in the
hands of individuals and our militia
groups a toxic waste dumping across
borders 12 billion dollars and as I as I
mentioned that the trading people is a
grow as large it is growing it is about
10 billion dollars per year and just a
factoid he took 400 years to bring 12
million people from Africa to the new
world during the slave trade just in the
last 10 years 30 million people have
been trafficked in Asia so it is
acquiring a spectacular volume size it
is also becoming far more global far
more international and anything having
as i said is having very important
consequences in the way in which
governments work everywhere when I
looked at the trades I found that they
had even though they're very disparate
the trading DVDs is certainly very
different that the trade in marijuana or
the trade in people yet I found similar
many but let me just highlight for the
first is that in all cases these traits
Pete government's against markets in all
single instance of those that I
described there are government's trying
to contain trying to stop these
activities from going on first and that
says that this is much about money and
about profits in the book I keep
repeating that these trays is it is not
about they're not driven by low morals
they're driven by high profits and
approaching this thing this trace just
as a morality tale will only take you so
far because they will be prophets and
will be circumstances and will be human
deeds that I will be completely immune
to morality appeals on appeals to
morality that's the first its markets
and and governments trying to contain
the markets the second thing that it was
very interesting to me is that these all
of these markets are now global the
importance of geography is no longer
that important the same forces of
globalization that shrunk the world in
the 90s and that allowed nongovernmental
organizations to go global and operate
in multiple countries environmental
groups human rights groups and the such
faith based groups that are
collaborating international terrorists
businesses that there now can operate
across borders and across the world far
more easily than they were able to do it
before thanks to what did the
transformational revolutionary
technologies of the 90s of course new
technologies and the internet prepaid
phone cards cheap travel opportunities
everywhere together with the revolutions
of the 90s that open the borders the
political changes of the 90s the
collapse of the Soviet Union the opening
of China the the dismantling of a lot of
the trade barriers that existed in the
world governments that initiated
economic reforms that essentially a
not allowing a freer exchange of people
money ideas goods all of that dissolved
the sealants that governments used to
rely upon to control the borders and all
of that made life easier for the
traffickers and harder from governments
and all of that also contributed to make
geography less of a factor that is why
in the book I tell the stories of
Nigerian traffickers operating northern
Thailand Ukrainian weapons traffickers
working in cahoots with Bolivian and
Colombian drug traffickers that in turn
launder the money through Russian
networks of money launderers in New York
Moroccan traffickers of people and
hashish working with a Spanish
traffickers of counterfeits and so on
what you see is these different
nationalities these different groups
working along long-range distances and
coordinating the other thing that's very
important is that these groups are no
longer the Mafia the Mafia model where
you had a pyramid you had a boss and
then the boss had some underlings and
then there were some captains and
lieutenants and the typical that's no
longer the way this operates is about
cells it's about small groups stateless
agile wealthy ruthless violent and
capable of moving very quickly from and
shifting from one market to another
depending on opportunities and threats
and one day they can be trading women
for prostitution and the next day they
can be trading on stolen cars or
smuggled cigarettes there are
specialists in logistics they're
specialists in transportation they're
specialists in how to move goods and
people across borders booths and people
that are prohibited from moving across
borders and those very agile networks
are not bound by geography and that's
why they can create opportunities and
work together with like-minded
operational networks elsewhere and just
create a network that has these ability
to
work from African connect Africa to
South Asia Asia and and Russia and New
York that was my second a common
characteristic for all these trades the
third has to do with borders national
boundaries as i already said national
boundaries have become a blessing for
traffickers and a nightmare for
governments governments are designed and
operated to leave the inside national
borders the natural habitat for a
government is inside the country inside
their jurisdiction for a government
official for a government agency to
operate across borders is as artificial
to as any of us to work on the water
they need as much support and as much
aunt official lungs to work across
borders as we need to work on the water
governments are essentially domestic of
course you can have treaties and you
have embassies and you have ambassadors
but all of that requires very complex
artificial constructs among government
bureaucracies that are slow and
cumbersome and difficult while the
habitat of governments is national is
inside borders the natural the natural
habitat of traffickers is in between is
across borders they thrive in the world
of in between in between borders across
borders transnational stateless and so
borders provide to traffickers first the
profit opportunities because they squat
creates the price differences is what is
that what allows them to buy very
inexpensively in one place and sell very
expensively in another place across the
border and borders also provide shelter
you commit a crime in one place and you
move across the border and of course
there is extradition and there is an
Interpol and there is all of that but
all of that is slow and difficult and
complex and these are farm wealthier
fast moving and agile that all of the
law enforcement capabilities that are
trying to contain them
that's the third the fourth common
characteristic is a worrisome one and
that is the nog government can claim any
success in containing this trait there
is not one single instance in which any
government can tell you that they have
achieved sustained success in curbing
these markets think about the drug trade
the war on drugs in this country was
launched by Richard Nixon decades ago it
now costs and estimated forty billion
dollars a year each year this country
spends 40 billion dollars in trying to
contain the importation of drugs and
contain the distribution of drugs yet
government statistics show that
government that that drug use has not
declined significantly that drugs are
widely available there is no evidence
that in our high schools drugs are hard
to get in many many high schools is
harder for high schoolers to get a pack
of cigarettes than to get a cigarette of
marijuana despite all the efforts think
about weapons think about when was the
last time that anyone heard that an
armed guerrilla movement a militia had
to go out of business because it
couldn't get the weapons of the
ammunition you need it there none if a
group is armed and active and has some
funding it will get the weapons despite
the embargoes and the blockades the
military interventions and the treaties
and the United Nations and the European
Union's still if you have an insurgency
and you have money you're going to get
the weapons think also about a
counterfeit when was the last time that
any of us felt any jitters about
purchasing one of these counterfeits in
the streets that's a risk activity you
can just go out and buy a counter
feedback I watch a garment no risks but
of course we have a lot of complaining
and a lot of anxiety about the
counterfeiting industry looking at this
force not looking at the demand
think about the trafficking in people
after nine before nine eleven about half
a million five hundred thousand illegal
immigrants entered the United States
each year on average during the night
after nine eleven there was a surge of
anxiety and need to protect and fortify
the borders and this country passed
several laws and pad patriot act and and
Sarah and made it more difficult to
enter the country recently a study
showed that after nine eleven the number
of illegal immigrants entering the
United States is 500,000 exactly the
same as it had been in the 90s or money
laundering I asked a a Swiss banker how
mar ha firm how much more difficult was
it now for him if a client came and
asked him to quote unquote manage 50
million dollars and by managed I mean
hide it from governments and move it
around the world how more difficult it
is now well he smiled and told me well
the only difference is now I charge more
and that is confirmed by a study there's
a book out just recently by the
International Institute of economics by
two very well-known respected experts
that studied the effects of the
anti-money laundering system line placed
again after nine eleven the idea was
that if you control the sources of funds
of the terrorists you can first monitor
them and also try to dry up their supply
line so to speak and so they started for
four years all sorts of methods that
were used to try to estimate the impact
of the anti-money laundering system
which is very expensive it is very
active it's very aggressive and their
conclusion was that the probability of
being caught if you are a money
launderer in the United States is five
percent and far lower elsewhere so the
point is that in all of these instances
the markets are growing and they go
remains of failing at containing their
the growth which brings me to the
inevitable question where what to do
what to do the book has a chapter the
book illicit has a chapter are titled
what to do in which there are several
specific initiatives are and and ways of
acting are described and here i will
just mention three first is that it's
very important to have a more Frank
national conversation about these things
essentially around all of these trades
there is huge hypocrisy when people ask
me about what is my book about well my
book is both about arbitrage and
hypocrisy arbitrage is the name that
traders and financier is used to buying
in one place or the one one price and
selling at another at a higher price
that's arbitrage and hypocrisy is what
surrounds the national conversation
about all these things we are we are
very worried about illegal aliens and
about the legal workers and but the fact
of the matter is that American companies
don't face much risks in employing these
illegal workers the number of fines that
the American government has imposed in
corporations for violating for hiring
illegal aliens has dropped eighty-two
percent in a decade the total number of
companies find in this country for
having employed illegal aliens the last
year for which we have number since 2003
the number of companies fine was 124
there are whole industries and we all
benefit from illegal workers here many
of us who eat at restaurants and if you
Justin have to go to the to the kitchen
and see who is working in the kitchens
and you will see that many of them are
illegal workers the food we eat is
cheaper because of illegal workers our
children and our elderly are taken care
increasingly by legal workers yet the
national conversation is about
they need to stop and cut and expel the
most extreme versions of it is to expel
illegal workers same with drugs there is
a America the United States is one of
the country in the world that has one of
the highest incarceration rates in the
world there are 7 million people in jail
in this country a large number of them
are in jail because of drugs and rock
and not only because they're drug
traffickers but many of them are just
caught with drugs many of them are
caught with marijuana yet marijuana is
amply available cocaine is widely
available and yet it continues to be
this prohibition that essentially is
highly hypocritical the same as example
with counterfeits as I said before when
was the last time that anyone worried
about buying a counterfeited fake watch
in fact it has become part of the
lifestyle they say we joke about it and
so on so very little will happen and
it's almost pointless to talk about what
to do if we first don't talk about the
double standards that we use in talking
about these things and after we accept
this reality the notion that we have to
look at these trades in a marshal active
way by no means I am an advocate of
getting the government out of trying to
contain these trades there are some of
them that are harrowing they're horrible
and the threaten all of us our families
our stability in our futures I want the
government to be very very effective at
controlling the international trade in
small children or in women exploited for
prostitution or on weapons of mass
destruction but I don't know is it that
it is the best use of our collective tax
payer money to have governments chasing
after all of the DVD straight or the
chase or marijuana unavoidably the
government has to be more selective we
will make no progress if we ask the
government to be in a total prohibition
mode in all of these trades that is said
government to failure and therefore set
ourselves to failure
thank you very much and let me stop here
and just take your questions yes thank
you what a great talk you'll be happy to
know that in Venice they have a brochure
now in every single hotel advising you
not to buy these handbags that are sold
on the street with my question by yeah
right right my question and a fine
there's a huge fight if you do my
question concerns the illegal drugs and
medical izing drugs it seemed to me for
a long time that if they were
medicalized that is to say you could get
them through your doctor if you're an
addict and if they were sold like
alcohol and cigarettes and text that the
government would start facing reality
and stop as you say chasing after this
it hasn't worked it's been how many
years and how much money I wonder what
she saw this yeah i agree with you
that's i interviewed the book in the
book i mentioned an interview had a with
a senator and the senator was very
candid with me and told me i know that
what we're doing with drugs is not
working and i know that we have to
change it but i also know that the
moment i say this i'm going to be voted
out of office that is why the
conversations about these straits have
to start not in capitol hill but in our
dinner tables and that is why we have to
be more Frank they I am NOT for the
legalization of drugs across the board I
think they're you know what's happening
in this country with methamphetamines
which is terrible and needs to be
regulated and controlled but look at
cigarettes the number of teenagers that
are smoking cigarettes is going down and
the campaign that this country has waged
persuading and educating people that
smoke
cigarette skills has been very effective
yet because we have the illusion that
they are not rock smoking because is
illegal there are no campaigns that to
speak of there is just a fraction of the
forty billion dollars that we are spent
each year in this country to try to on
the war on drugs only a fraction is
spent on education the rest is spent on
high seas chasing and all the telegenic
far more sexy activities that are
associated with a drug trade and I by no
means I want to the right there are
there some heroes doing these and their
people you know their law enforcement
and Drug Enforcement individuals that
are risking risking their lives on a
daily basis on a very risky endeavor but
they are the first to know that they
will they are the first to tell you that
doing it the way we're doing it is not
working well I confess that I am the
owner of a counterfeit Hermes bag my
question is whom do you hope to
influence with this book who will have
could take a strategic part in in
stopping the dark side of globalism I as
I said before nothing will happen unless
you and people that are watching on
television and others that are reading
the book start understanding and begin
to understand and the just denouncing
these trades and not at the same time
consuming and benefiting from them is a
double standard that is threatening us
and what I in my point is that this is
not just a crime one of the most
dangerous intellectual complacency zycie
around today is the notion that crime
has been around forever prime is as old
as humanity and therefore this is just
but one more expression of crime and
criminal activity and so it comes with
the territory of being human and living
in society there's nothing new here well
the point of my book is that there's
plenty that is new and if we don't pay
attention is going to road very
fundamental principles on which we live
and like to leave and would like to
continue living and therefore the first
message is to first connect the dots it
is very interesting after you know if
you read the book you will start
discovering that you read the newspaper
in a different way each day you will
find in the newspapers and in the news
reports of costs of different kinds of
activities of different kinds and if you
start connecting them and discover that
day and realize that they're part of the
same phenomenon that I'm describing it
is a different way of understanding
where the world is heading you cannot
understand how the seizure making is
taking place today in China without
understanding the impact of the illicit
economy you cannot understand things
like reconstruction national
reconstruction in Iraq without
understanding the role of crime you
cannot understand international trade
international finance if you don't take
into account these things and you would
only do so by integrating the views and
an understanding that these are
manifestations of value of a single
phenomenon driven by globalization which
in turn was boosted by the technological
and political changes of the nineties so
the first message is for all of us that
eventually will go to politicians and
create the political will to do things
differently I'm Allen Mandel I think
that the growing problem that you
describe is truly frightening on the
other hand is also the issue of civil
liberties some people who profess to be
against illicit trade would lead
advocate solutions that would lead to
the instigation of a police state and
the erosion of civil liberties could you
talk about that that's a great point and
I thank you for raising it I do talk
about it in the book and there is a
tension between fighting and trying to
contain some of these and take you for
granted some of the civil liberties and
privacy and
what we have all i have to say at this
point is that there is new technology
coming online that will erode some of
these civil liberties and what you have
also noticed is that these are tools and
as tools what's important is not only
the tools but he uses them and so when
you put these tools in the hands of
governments we have a long history of
governments means using tools in
horrible ways but at the same time this
is a debate that can we cannot avoid at
the same time all every society has to
go through the debate of balancing what
are the impacts of some of these illicit
rates is having in the fabric of society
and the values and security of everyone
and what are the erosion of civil
liberties that are going to go and you
saw it you saw it after nine eleven you
saw a country that was very willing to
put up with an tolerate changes that
we're intolerable before you saw the
tolerance for a closed circuit TV
cameras after the bombings in London now
you know before everybody was
apprehensive about that now people are
willing to live with those if they
provide a modicum of more security will
that yield to abuse it probably it's
unavoidable and it has happened in
history that governments given powerful
in privacy intruding technologies will
use them abusively but one has to trust
that there are checks and balances that
will operate and again it's a debate
that we need to have and that I refuse
to just state and make a blanket
statement that therefore because civil
liberties are important and the no
technologies and no initiatives should
be considered or to say that because
these trades are threatening us we
should throw all civil liberties out the
window I don't think that any of the two
captures but the complex debate we have
to have as a country and the world
evening mr. name I in your research what
have you uncovered on the illicit trade
in components to construe
the tactical nuclear weapon nuclear bomb
and how complicit are various groups in
this underworld with governments such as
Iran North Korea formerly Pakistan QA
cons network I believe this is perhaps
the single most dangerous of the illicit
problems that you were discussing and
how close in your estimation based on
your research are we perhaps timewise in
all of this coming together in turn
actual construction of a tactical
nuclear weapon that could be brought
across the border and detonated in a
city such as Washington or New York I
agree with you that of all the trades I
discuss the trade in bomb making nuclear
materials is the most dangerous and
that's what i said i am more willing to
tolerate the illicit trade in
counterfeit dvds and move in hollywood
movies and have government center
closely on these others day lisa trade
in nuclear materials exists in his large
and it poses a fantastic paradox about
how to see the world from the
perspective of the book and from our
traditional ways of thinking about
international politics as this and all
of this country was transfixed all of us
were transfixed for invasion of Iraq the
United States was going to go in because
of weapons of mass destruction and he
did need to contain that weapons of mass
destruction that we never found at
exactly the same time there was this
illicit network led by a pakistani
engineer called AQ Khan who is the
father of Pakistan's atomic program that
had said he had gone private in the name
well Phi D ology and the national
interest all that but at the end of the
day it was a for-profit operation he had
operations he had partners in South
Africa he had a manufacturing operation
in Malaysia he had banks in the Gulf in
the Middle East and operations that also
touched Switzerland and so on it was a
very complex complex network
like the ones I have described here
except that the specialty was bomb made
it was centrifuged it was machinery and
technology that is needed to manufacture
atomic bombs and he was doing it for
profit not for God not for religion not
for politics he was doing it for profit
of course he would tell you that he was
doing it to advance the cause and and he
and so on and there is evidence that he
did he was trying he was captured when
in trying to when it was discovered that
he was shipping these things to Libya
and there is suspicion that he might
have sold it elsewhere a very top
intelligence official said that they q
can we go down in history as having
destabilized the world and created more
insecurity at some of the worst d
stabilizers of the world in the 20th
century so there is and he's not alone
there are Scud missiles that have
disappeared in Ukraine there are missile
propel the manpads we call them which
are Rockets rocket launchers that can
bring down an airliner that are there's
a market for that and so yes there is a
market for that and it is big money and
profits are involved and therefore
that's the area where I would like over
mr. concentrate the most and eve more
effective thank you so much for your
work so could you please talk about the
government itself being involved in
corruption and where I'm going with this
question is for example governments and
sells property or gives a seal on
property in Egypt or India very quickly
to large businesses that intellectuals
are the upper class like us want to
travel to through a marriott want to
stay in a marriott but the mayor really
got the property using the government to
seal the property very quickly for its
name vs it takes a one-year for the
local to buy the same property unless
they provide corruption to the
government for thirty thousand dollars
or whatever you know what almost is
value of the property so the government
is actually involved in corruption and
we are you know the upper class who
wants to stay in these places feed the
corruption and this is another form of
illicit in a work but you know could you
could you talk about us actually
contributing to the problem as well as
the government yes I and corruption is
again corruption is as old as humanity
and I don't mean to say that therefore
there is on anything new under the sun
and that therefore corruption has become
and I want to be very specific about the
sort of government involvement that I am
talking about in this illicit trades I'm
talking for example about the fact that
the head of the security forces and one
of the most influential individuals in
peru by the name of vladimir montesinos
who during the 90s was in charge of that
country's intelligence anti-drug and and
and and an antic guerrilla movements and
all of that is today in jail because
he's accused of having been the leader
of a network that was active in trading
weapons and drugs and laundering money
i'm talking about the former president
of lithuania that is now what was
impeached when he was caught in
conversations with some elements of a
network of a Russian network that
eventually that obviously had him in the
payroll I'm talking about again there
are two kinds here there is the
government involvement that is just some
bad apples some corrupt individuals that
are being bought off by these networks
that could not operate and could not get
to the numbers i have given without
government involvement and so there are
some bad apple cases but then there are
some structural government's there are
government's that are structurally
criminal that have and think again about
different different
vlo rusia in Belarus it is an example
trans Nestor is another example North
Korea there's plenty of evidence that
the North Korea government is very
actively involved and engaged in all
sorts of illicit rates and uses illicit
trades to fund its operations so these
are structural conditions and their
governments that are structure involved
and and and that is what makes it very
difficult because in order to stamp out
some of the things you have to work with
different governments and so how do you
work with different governments if you
don't know that the people with whom you
are collaborating and in fact complicit
with the with the networks the question
of trying to ask was the government
actually causing the problem for example
with the corruption and the real estate
in the pw know the public works and real
estate they actually create a bigger gap
between the rich and the poor and so the
poor become available for trafficking as
you know well your general point is
well-taken that is corruption very often
is a is a major source both of slow
growth a slow economic growth and more
poverty more inequality and that feeds
the trades at that's absolutely right
thank you I'm sorry I got here late you
may have already touched on this but I
was wondering if you could address to
what extent is one man's illicit economy
another man's informal sector and if one
accepts the the notion that the informal
sector is a major you know importance to
growth in a lot of developing countries
where do you draw what are the linkages
between the two where do you draw the
line what is the distinction that's a
great question and I just wrote a column
called the illicit continent I was
talking about Latin America recently
there was a summit of presidents of
Latin American presidents that could not
agree they were fighting over free trade
there's a group of presidents of the
United States and many others that as I
do think that free trade is good for the
region and there were other group of
presidents led by Hugo chávez venezuela
essentially don't like the idea of free
trade agreements like the ones we have
seen and there was this furious battle
and they couldn't even agree while that
battle was raging Latin America illicit
trade was tying the north of the south
of the continent in very powerful ways
free trade may not be booming in Latin
America and in the hemisphere but
illicit trade surely is there are there
is more money being sent each year by
Latin American illegal Latin America
immigrants to back to the countries that
all of the money sent by all of the
multinationals put together all of the
foreign aid doled out by the US
government or the European Union the
poor of Latin America that have moved
elsewhere notably here in the United
States are sending more capital to the
region that all of the multinationals in
the world very often those individuals
are illicit and very often the channels
they use because their illicit they
don't have bank accounts and so on so
the channels they have to use to send
the money back to the families are also
elicited Latin America exported 75
billion dollars worth of agriculture
last year the number the numbers the
equivalent numbers in drugs is many many
times higher so again well formal free
trade may not be booming illicit trades
are half of the employment in Latin
America is informal these are informal
workers that are not part of a normal
economy and a normal payroll and only
two percent of Latin American companies
are classified as large and even those
that are large or very small by world
standards so Latin America seems to
create habitats a conditions that
inhibits the formal economy and and
facilitates the informal of an illicit
economy and that is in support of your
point that very often that's the only
option being illicit being informal is
the only option that a significant chunk
of mankind has to make a living
last gentleman lover can't have to cut
it off hi I recently read an article
written by you where you argue that the
war on corruption has been actually a
bad medicine for um developing countries
i was wonder if you care to comment on
that yes you're referring to an article
where our i argued that there is in the
90s a very powerful movement against
corruption appeared in the world and
created all sorts of initiatives and my
argument was that the cures that we have
been using have been ineffective and in
fact counterproductive it's not because
i am for corruption because that will be
like being for cancer all I'm saying is
that the cures were using for that
cancer are very often killing patients
and we have no evidence that they have
they have cured anyone you mentioned
earlier that there you believe in sort
of selective enforcement that their
trades that you would like to see being
cracked down on like the nuclear trade
but there are other trades that you
would be okay tolerating for the for the
time being I was wondering if you could
comment on the human trafficking trade
because I know that uh it certainly
lands people in a horrible predicament
sometimes like the people you described
who are financially bound to crime
organizations but I think it also bears
asking about people like asylum seekers
who are fleeing persecution in other
countries and who for them human
trafficking is the only way out and so I
was just wondering if you think we
should enforce more or less or you think
it's good or bad the people trafficking
has two components has won a group of
people that is the great majority there
are voluntarily trafficked is the mother
in Guatemala that seeks a coyote a
trafficker
and pays him or money to take her to the
United States and that is a very human
basic impulse to get more money that be
and to be able to put more food and
hopefully a future and give a future to
the children and she's doing this
voluntarily and if she's caught she's
going to do it again and again again
until she achieves a better future a
better situation for her family and I
could tell you it's it's the quad a man
and woman but it could be the Chinese
cook or it can be the Albanian mother
that goes to Italy the Moroccan father
that sends his 19 year old boy in a
rickety boat to Spain in the hope that
he will find work in the future so these
are very human impulses which and then
there is the other dimension of people
trafficking which is the horrible
kidnapping the horrible abused
exploitation and all of that in which
people are and very often they mingle
beacon and they mesh because you hope
the woman from Albania hopes to go to
London to work as a nurse and then she's
kidnapped beaten up exploited and forced
to work as a prostitute and and so that
is the kind of thing that I think needs
a lot of enforcement a lot of control
and a lot of government effective
governor intervention the other one also
the only one is nothing but one of the
great challenges of our time which is
migration and migration touches
everything and we have seen the riots in
france and once with the debates about
multiculturalism and the difficulty of
sealing our borders and all of the
issues on migration again whenever you
hear a syllable a silver bullet a
one-liner about migration be very
suspicious because probably not not very
precise you cannot open the borders and
allow everyone that wants to come here
to come here closing the Borders and
hoping that fences and moats and the
walls are going to do the job is also an
illusion and so what what we know is
that what we have is not working what we
know is that we have creating the
mousetrap affect the mousetrap when once
the mouse enters
to the trap can never leave we have
created a situation where the people
that come here for work it's so costly
it's so risky so dangerous that once
they are here they have a very hard time
going back and so facilitating turnover
and allowing them to come and go more
often maybe a solution we don't know
that it will work and in all of these
one needs to be very open-minded and
experimental and some of these ideas may
not work but start with the premise that
we have for a long time suffered with a
collective learning disability disorder
we have had a great difficulty learning
from experience we have been prone to
repeating again and again policies that
we know do not work and yet we have the
social constructed difficulty of
accepting that some of the things that
we're doing are not working I don't know
what works what I know is that is worth
experimenting Mary Dominic former
liaison for Senator to the array
encounter committee I wondered whether
in your research you had heard of the
MENA cartel in Arkansas a dirt strip
north of Little Rock where drugs were
run from Nicaragua allegedly are
purportedly by CIA and whether or not
you addressed this it comes to the point
about the cure perhaps the people
promoting the cure or perpetrators and
I'm not quite as optimistic as you are
in your last chapter thank you thank you
very much yes I know exactly the case
you mentioned it is one of many the
truth of the matter is that this is just
one more episode where traffickers and
the prophets available generate all
sorts of very know very very bold very
difficult initiatives and we have seen
plenty we have seen tunnels being dug on
the border we have seen the Colombian
traffickers once purchasing Russian
submarine and retrofitting the submarine
to be able to carry drugs we have seen
all sorts if you go into the actual
details of how this is done you will
find that there is a this boundless
creativity in trying to move bangles
across borders because at the other end
of the border is a pot of gold thank you
very much thank you